here now with more is someone who has
followed the money for quite some time
Wisconsin Senator Ron Johnson you know
Senator Johnson you've been all over
this I I can't say I'm surprised that
Karine jeanpierre doesn't want to answer
questions we just scrolled 20 pieces of
evidence but don't the American people
deserve more from the White House you
can't try to coordinate strategy with
Hunter as reports suggest and then
Stonewall the
Press well merry Christmas and yes the
American people deserve the truth and
that's exactly what the house is going
about doing they are building on the
record that Senator grassy and I built
in terms of the inflow of tens of
millions of dollars from you know
countries that are adversarial to this
nation you know the binds did nothing
and then what chairman comr and Jordan
and Smith have been doing is they've
been feeling all the details you know
where did this money flow out to uh the
IRS whistleblowers were key but let's
face it the the it's been known that the
bidens have been operating something
called Biden Inc I didn't term that I
didn't coined that term that coined I
think political years ago so the Press
was on to the bidens that they knew that
the bidens were selling influence
trading off the the family name but once
he became president once he became the
candidate of the Democrats they buried
it all uh they undermined our
investigation said that Senator grass
and I were soliciting deeming Russian
disinformation does that sound familiar
so again this has been a massive coverup
uh you see the corruption within the the
news media but you also see corruption
within our federal law enforcement the
FBI the intelligence agencies which
which is as big a story if not bigger
than the corruption of the of the Biden
Inc crime
family no it's a huge Story I mean look
I I look at the testimony from from
Joseph Ziggler from these whistleblowers
Gary shapley these are not partisan
figures these are people who are not
Republicans these are people who have
integrity and came forward and said we
watched our investigation be stymied
time and time again again I mean is this
how the government operates will cover
up for Biden Inc and takes a
whistleblower a man of great courage to
come forward to stop
it yes I mean that is what has been
revealed you know dating back to the H
Hil Clint email Scandal where you had
that same cast characters that were in
charge of Crossfire hurricane they're
the ones that did the editing of the
James KY exoneration memo of Hillary
Clinton so this corruption's existed
quite some time uh it is a major Story
the corruption in the media a major
story but we also need to get the truth
on the bidens and I thought was probably
very interesting about the indictment is
all the cash that Hunter Biden went
through over the four years where he
wouldn't pay $1.4 million in taxes he
spent $4.9 million $1.6 million of that
was in cash that's $1,000 a day by the
way is that maybe how Joe Biden got his
10% as the big guy in untraceable Cold
Hard Cash those are the kinds of
questions that chairman com needs to ask
Connor Biden in a you know sworn you
know a sworn affidavit in a sworn
deposition that's why they need to get
him behind closed doors and pepper him
with questions from from legal
experts you mentioned the 4.9 million
and what's interesting about that you
have Kevin Morris you know this star
studded attorney who reportedly
according to Joseph zegler lent Hunter
Biden $4.9 million for all kinds of
payments I mean who just shells out
money and says hey here you go why why
did he do that more influence pedaling
what is
this that's another $64,000 Question
isn't it it's obvious some kind of H
influence pedling he's expecting
something in return now people don't
just shell out that kind of money
without expecting something in return
you know another thing that's I think
very troubling I think the media really
needs to ask this you know Hunter I know
you're troubled I know you had a drug
problem but not everybody the drug
problem spends 800 ,000 on women and
adult entertainment abusing sext
trafficked women that that that'd be a
question for the media how many women
Hunter did you abuse there were
trafficked through International sex
trafficking Rings is grotesque and you
know I I know President Biden was was
shelling out or offering to pay about
$100,000 over four-month period when
Hunter was spending tens of thousands of
dollarss on these women so again this is
corruption it is vile and for Hunter to
come out here and play the sympathy card
and say that you know we're we're
attacking him we're not we just need to
get to the truth because an American
president uh part of this the head the
top the Pinnacle of this Biden crime
family is compromised and it could be
impacting our national
security when you say it's a question
for the media I can tell you if I was
standing at the podium the president's
name was Donald Trump and you had the
hyenas in the Press Corp the question
would be asked Senator Johnson thank you
very much hey hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else